C'est précisément cette répression politique et sociale,
associée à des décennies de colonialisme
et d'une mauvaise éducation
qui a lentement érodé l'importance de l'alphabet arabe dans la région.
Tous ces pays ont un jour utilisé l'arabe.
Il ne reste plus que ceux en vert et bleu.
Pour faire simple,
l'alphabet arabe se meurt.
Dans les pays arabes d'après la décolonisation
évoluant dans une société de plus en plus mondialisée,
il est inquiétant
que de moins en moins de gens utilisent l'alphabet arabe pour communiquer.
Alors que j'étudiais pour mon master en Italie, l'arabe m'a manqué.
Cela me manquait de regarder les lettres,
de digérer leur sens.
Alors un jour, je suis entrée dans l'une des plus grandes bibliothèques d'Italie
à la recherche d'un livre arabe.
J'ai découvert avec surprise ce qu'ils avaient
dans la catégorie « Livres arabes/du Moyen-Orient ».
[NdT : ISIS = Daech]
(Rires)
La peur, le terrorisme et la destruction.
Un mot : Daech.
Cela m'a fait mal au cœur
que nous soyons ainsi représentés dans le monde,
même d'un point de vue littéraire.
Je me suis demandé : qu'est-il arrivé aux écrivains de renommée mondiale
comme Naguib Mahfouz, Khalil Gibran,
aux poètes emblématiques comme Mutanabbi, Nizar Qabbani ?
Réfléchissez-y.
Les produits culturels de toute une région du monde,
aussi riche, aussi diversifiée,
ont été jugés superflus,
voire complètement ignorés.
Les produits culturels de toute une région du monde
ont été exclus, ils ne peuvent pas avoir une quelconque réelle incidence
sur les productions mondiales des médias ou le discours social contemporain.
Puis je me suis remémorée ma plus forte conviction :
le graphisme peut changer le monde.
Il suffit que quelqu'un aperçoive votre travail,
ressente, établisse un lien.
Alors j'ai commencé.
J'ai réfléchi à comment mettre un terme
à la vision démoniaque que le monde a de nous,
en tant que terroristes de cette planète,
et comment être perçus d'égal à égal,
comme des êtres humains.
Comment puis-je sauver l'honneur de l'alphabet arabe
et le partager avec d'autres peuples, d'autres cultures ?
Cela m'a frappée :
et si je conjuguais les deux symboles les plus importants
de l'innocence et de l'identité arabe ?
Peut-être que les gens s'y retrouveraient.
Qu'y a-t-il de plus pur, innocent et amusant que LEGO ?
C'est un jeu universel.
Vous jouez avec, vous construisez avec
et vous pouvez imaginer des possibilités infinies.
Mon éclair de génie a été de trouver une solution bilingue d'éducation arabe
car une communication et une éducation efficaces
sont le chemin vers des communautés plus tolérantes.
Cependant, les alphabets arabes et latins représentent des mondes différents
mais créent aussi des difficultés techniques
pour les communautés orientales et occidentales
au quotidien.
L'arabe et le latin sont différents pour de multiples raisons,
mais voici les principales.
Les deux utilisent des traits vers le haut et le bas,
mais ont un référentiel très différent.
L'arabe a tendance à être plus calligraphique
et la connectivité est importante dans la langue arabe,
dont les lettres doivent souvent être attachées
afin d'articuler un mot donné.
Il utilise aussi un tout autre système de ponctuation et diacritique.
Mais surtout,
l'arabe n'a pas de majuscules.
Au lieu de cela, il a quatre formes de lettres :
initiale, médiane, isolée et finale.
Je veux présenter la langue arabe aux jeunes apprenants, aux non natifs,
mais surtout aider les réfugiés à intégrer leur société d'accueil
en créant un système d'apprentissage bilingue,
une communication dans les deux sens.
Je l'ai appelé « Let's Play ».
L'idée est simplement de créer
une méthode d'apprentissage amusante et stimulante
pour l'arabe standard moderne grâce aux LEGO.
Voici les deux mots « Let's Play ».
Chaque barre de couleur marque une lettre arabe.
Vous pouvez voir que la lettre est expliquée via sa forme, son son
et des exemples de mots où elle apparaît,
ainsi que son équivalent en latin.
Ensemble, elles forment un carnet amusant
avec les 29 lettres arabes et les quatre formes différentes,
ainsi qu'un dictionnaire de 400 mots.
Voici ce à quoi les pages ressemblent.
Vous avez la lettre, la translittération en latin
et la description en-dessous.
Je vais vous expliquer le processus.
Dans mon petit studio à Florence,
j'ai créé les lettres.
J'ai photographié chaque lettre séparément ,
j'ai retouché chaque lettre et choisi la couleur de l'arrière-plan
et la police de caractères.
Finalement, j'ai créé l'ensemble de lettres :
29 lettres fois quatre formes différentes.
Cela représente 116 lettres créées en une semaine seulement.
Je crois que les informations doivent et peuvent être amusantes, portables.
Ce livre est le produit final,
que j'aimerais publier
et traduire dans autant de langues qu'il y a dans le monde
afin qu'enseigner et apprendre l'arabe devienne amusant, facile
et accessible à l'échelle mondiale.
Avec ce livre, j'espère sauver le bel alphabet de ma nation.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Travailler sur ce projet a été une forme de méditation visuelle,
comme une danse soufie,
une prière pour une meilleure planète.
Un jeu de blocs de construction a créé deux langues.
Les LEGO ne sont qu'une métaphore.
C'est parce que nous sommes tous composés des mêmes éléments
que je vois un avenir
où les barrières entre les gens
s'écroulent toutes.
Peu importe la laideur du monde qui nous entoure,
combien de livres décourageants sur Isis/Daech, le groupe terroriste,
pas Isis, l'ancienne déesse égyptienne,
continuent d'être publiés,
je continuerai à créer un monde plein de couleurs.
Shukran, ce qui signifie « merci ».
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci beaucoup.
Merci.